So one of the things that goes wrong, when you try to
actually run gradient descent on a complex network with a lot of data
is that you can get stuck in these local minima and then
you start to wonder, boy is there some other way that I can
optimize these weights. I'm trying to find a set of weights for
the neural network Well that what? That, that tries to ,minimize error on
the training set. And so, gradient decent is one way to do
it, and it can get stuck, but there's other kinds of advanced optimization
methods that become very appropriate here. And in fact, there's
a lot of people in machine learning who think of optimization
and learning as kind of being the same thing. That, that
what you're really trying to do in any kind of learning
problem is solve this, this high order, very difficult optimization
problem to figure out what the The learned ,representation needs to
be. So, I need to mention in passing some kinds of
advanced methods that people have brought to bear, there's things like
,uh,using momentum terms in the gradient,
which basically, where the idea in momentum
is, as we're doing gradient decent, so let's imagine this is our error
surface, we don't want to get stick on this ball here, we want to
kind of pass all the way through it to get to this ball, so maybe
we need to just continue in the direction we've been going. So, instead
of You know think of it as a kind of physical analogy. Instead
of just, just going to the bottom of this hill and getting stuck,
it can kind of bounce out and pop over and come to, what might be
a lower, minima, later. There's a lot of
work in using higher order derivatives to, to better
optimize things instead of just thinking about the,
way that individual weights change the error function to
look at combinations of weights. Hamiltonions and whatnot.
There's various ideas for randomized optimization, which we're going
to get to in a sister course, that can
be applied to, to, to make things more robust.
And sometimes it's worth thinking, you know what, we don't really want to just
minimize the error on the training set, we may actually want to have some
kind of penalty for using, using a structure that's too complex. I mean this,
this ,uh, when did we, when did we see something like this before Charles?
>> When we were doing regression, and we were talking about over fitting.
>> So right. That's right. It came up in
regression but something similar will also happen in the decision
tree section.
>> Sure. We, we had a, we had a issue with
decision trees where if we had, we let the tree grow too
much to explain every little quirk in the data. You'd over fit,
and so ,we came up with a lot of ways of dealing
with that, like pruning. No going too far deeply into the tree.
You can either do that by filling out the tree and then
backing up so you only have a little bit of small error
Or by stopping once you've reached some sort of threshold as you
grow the tree out. That's really the same
as giving some kind of penalty for complexity.
>> Yes, exactly, right. So complexity in the
tree setting has to do with the size
of the tree, in regression it had to do with the order of the polynomial. What
do you suppose it would mean in the neural net setting? And, and how would you
predict, what negative attributes it might have. So,
what's, what's a more or less complex network?
>> Well, there's two things you can do
with networks, you can add more and more
nodes, and you can add more and more layers.
>> Good. So, right. So if we, the more
nodes that we put into network, the more complicated
the mapping becomes from input to output, the more
local minima we get, the more we have the ability
to actually model the noise, which brings up exactly
the same overfitting issues. It turns out there's another one
that's actually really interesting in the neural net setting
which, I think didn't occur to people In the early
days but it became clear and clear over time,
which is that ,you can also have a complex network,
just because the numbers, the weights, are very large. So
same number of weights, same number of nodes, same number
of layers, but larger numbers often leads to more complex.
Network and the possibility of overfitting. And so ,sometimes we
want to penalize a network not just by giving it
fewer nodes or layers but also by keeping the numbers
in a reasonable range. Does that, does that make sense?
>> Makes perfect sense.